we all want to be happy but the majority
of us have no idea what to do see the
Japanese have a concept called ikigai
which roughly translates into a reason
for being you need to have a purpose for
being here but this is easier said than
done because there are four components
that you need to check off in order to
achieve ikigai the third component for
ikigai is that it needs to be something
that you can get paid well for some of
you are automatically going to say
something like oh Improvement pill you
don't need money in order to be happy
but let's be real money is what puts a
roof over your head food in your mouth
and clothes on your body without enough
of it you're gonna spend the majority of
your time stressed out of your mind
wondering how you're going to get by and
it's not enough to just be making some
money you need to be getting paid well
enough to live a comfortable life if
you're not making enough money to live
without stress then you will never
achieve happiness follow us for more
helpful tips